so picking
people that's what we're on tell me
about it well I think that's the number
one thing is to try to get it right on
the way in the door um
and you know understanding what you what
you need um and what you're looking for
so um as we like to say um if you don't
know where you're going any road will
take you there so we try to define the
path of of what we're looking for in
terms of the traits uh the athletic
qualities the competitiveness and so
forth um know by position and to
identify that and and then try to select
those people that we feel like will fit
into our culture and into our program um
because it's so hard to change them if
they don't have those qualities it's
it's really hard to uh you know you can
mold a little bit but it's it's hard to
fundamentally change selfish to
unselfish as an example so um that's
really the selection part of it is is
really important for us on the beginning
and and um in in our business we start
with 90
players uh and then we go to 53 so 37
players get fired every year um and one
of the things that I learned from Jack
Welch uh one of his great axioms was
treat him the same way on the way out as
you treat them on the way in you're
happy to have them on the way in you
love them on the way in it doesn't work
out
you feel the same way about them on the
way out I me unless there's been some
extraordinary circumstance but sometimes
it just doesn't work out where you have
to move on and it's your probably your
fault as much as it is anybody else's
because you didn't select the right
person but in the end you know we move
on and treat them the same as the way in
as a way out but the selection process
at the beginning really is the key to I
think building the culture and building
the the organization that you
want